in response to the coronavirus crisis
researchers are working at a breakneck
pace to develop solutions that will
allow economies to reopen safely and
permanently without an effective vaccine
we won't be able to get this pandemic
under control
and stop the devastation that is
currently causing all around the globe
vaccines can take an average of 10 years
to develop according to a 2013 study but
researchers and pharmaceutical companies
are hoping to bring their vaccine
candidates for the new coronavirus to
market in 12 to 18 months some are even
talking about getting emergency use
authorization before the end of the year
so what is making it possible to
expedite this process so dramatically
there are several factors including
prior knowledge of coronaviruses
specifically SARS and MERS improvements
in sequencing of viral genomes
advancements in bio engineering
technologies unprecedented government
support and funding plus a shortened
testing timeline traditionally after
scientists develop a vaccine candidate
they run it through a series of tests
this starts in cells and then
transitions to animals usually beginning
with mice and eventually progressing to
monkeys testing only advances from one
phase to the next if it's proven to be
safe and effective at that stage you
would then likely perform what we call a
challenge study so that would be a
vaccination an animal then intentionally
giving them of the virus I'm seeing the
the impact of your vaccine on that
disease model where of course you would
hope to protect it then they'd use that
data to get approval from regulators
like the FDA to begin human testing
there are three stages of human trials
each one testing more people than the
last approval is required for each stage
instead of this relay approach where
researchers wrap up each set of
experiments before embarking on the next
round developers are now doing many
tests in parallel so we're not skipping
steps but we're doing things at the same
time which of course costs a lot more
and there's a lot more work than doing
it one after the other
that's the key difference the novel
coronavirus was discovered and sequenced
less than six months ago several
candidates are already in phase one of
human trials including those made by
inovio and Pfizer even as companies
await results from animal studies
moderna recently started phase two
others are gearing up for Phase two
before phase one wraps up our phase one
trial will run for a year but we're not
going to wait for that full year period
to elapsed before we hopefully move on
to the next stage of efficacy testing
because of the worry of ghovat 19 being
so devastating we are expediting those
processes and there's a lot of concern
that we because we don't really know all
that much about immunity to this virus
that we may be going too quickly but so
that's the balance here vaccines work on
a simple premise they trick the body
into thinking a virus has infiltrated it
so the immune system kicks into action
and starts producing antibodies and
other defenses against parts of the
virus in this case scientists think
their target is the spike protein which
the corona virus uses to get into cells
it's been shown from SARS and MERS
that's the spike protein is D major
protein on the outside of the virus of
these corona viruses to which you raise
neutralizing antibodies and neutralizing
antibodies is what you need to fight the
infection so what will really end the
pandemic is when there's enough immunity
in the population and either that
immunity comes from everybody getting
infected or it comes from a vaccine and
it's a much gentler path for everybody
to get get a vaccine than for everybody
to get infected this concept is known as
herd immunity dozens of companies and
labs are trying various technologies to
develop vaccines that would get us there
quickly scientists say it's the largest
most collaborative vaccine development
effort they've seen in their lifetimes
they're testing four main strategies
weakened viruses proteins viral vectors
and genetic code vaccines
weakened or inactivated virus vaccines
are the most common
that's your annual flu shot we have the
most experience with these but they can
also be costly and time-consuming to
mass-produce so in this case they
haven't been the preferred approach
protein based vaccines carry key parts
of the virus into the body for
coronavirus that's the spike protein
Sanofi in GlaxoSmithKline are among
dozens of developers taking this
approach for viral vector vaccines
scientists use an inactivated virus and
stuff it with a genetic code for the
spike protein which are cells then used
to turn out viral proteins the immune
system then recognizes those a sporran
Johnson & Johnson is developing this
type of vaccine for the corona virus we
use a nanovirus Victor and and this
adenovirus is a common cold virus which
normally doesn't cause any major disease
just a common goal and the NLL virus it
becomes replication in companies in the
fourth and final category our genetic
code vaccines these contain the
instructions for the spike protein kovat
vaccines being developed by inovio
Pfizer and moderna fall into this
category these types of vaccines have
never been approved for humans before
but they're generating a lot of
excitement the reason we're seeing them
out in front is is the speed the speed
in the manufacturing the development
yeah really really both proteins are
more diverse they have all kinds of
different shapes and characteristics and
so you have to play with a lot more to
actually get a protein based vaccine
made Pfizer is running multiple
candidates through phase one trials in
the US and Germany to cut down on
development time and even before we know
whether the vaccine works or not
we're starting to ramp up manufacturing
capacity so that we're ready to make it
right away
the key things you have to establish to
develop a vaccine are that it is safe
that it's effective and that every time
you make it it comes out the same
so those key steps don't change whether
you're going fast or you're going slow
changes in manufacturing can introduce
unforeseen issues that can make a
vaccine dangerous that's what happened
with the since discontinued polio
vaccine decades ago safety is a major
concern because vaccines are given to
healthy people so scientists have to
ensure they don't affect things like
liver or heart function among other
factors there are other issues as well
even if companies are able to come up
with a vaccine in less than two years
the vaccine research community is
concerned with how they'd be able to
produce and distribute it to everybody
on the planet so we are aiming to
produce 1 billion those by the end of
2021 and some other companies are
committing to the same kind of scale
either hundreds of millions or billions
but still it will not be enough for
everyone
what is a big unknown is what the
durability of that protection is is it
going to be a year two years or even
maybe unfortunately six months or less
because if it is measured in several
months instead of years which is
entirely conceivable that that would be
the case then we have a secondary
problem how often do you need to boost
somebody to keep that level of immunity
up the final and perhaps most important
hurdle for coronavirus vaccine
development would be human behavior our
people going to be accepting of this
vaccine that's been such a huge problem
in this country you know if you have 50%
of people saying I'm gonna take it under
any condition
then of course you've lost the whole
battle